on the Khan Academy web app which I need
to work on a little bit more to make it
a little bit faster they have this one
module that's called the graph of the
line it has no directions on it and I
thought I would make a little video here
at least to explain how to do this
module and in the process I think it'll
help people even those of you who aren't
using the module understand what the
slope and the y-intercept of a line is a
little bit better so this is a
screenshot of that module right here and
the idea is essentially to change this
line and this line right here in orange
is the line specified by this equation
right here
so right now it's the equation of the
line 1x plus 1 it has a slope of 1 you
can see that for every amount it moves
to the right it moves up exactly one and
has one for its y-intercept it
intersects the y-axis at exactly the
point 0 1 now the goal of this exercise
is to change your slope and your
y-intercept so that you go through these
two points at this point it's half of
its off the screen hopefully you can see
them if you're watching these in HD you
can see these you can see these two
points our goal is to make this line go
through them by essentially changing its
equation so it's a it's a kind of a
tactile way of you know as tactile is
something on the computer can get of
trying to figure out the equation of the
line that goes through these two points
so how can we do that so you can see
here when I change the slope if I make
the slope higher it becomes more steep
now the slope is 3 for every one I move
to the right I go have to go 3 up my
change in Y is 3 for every change in X
of 1 or that's my slope my y-intercept
is still 1 if I change my y-intercept if
I make it go down notice it just shifts
the line down it doesn't change its
inclination or its slope it just shifts
it down along this line right there so
how do I make my line go through those
two points well it looks like if I shift
it up enough let's shift up that point
and then let's say let's lower the slope
this looks like it has a negative slope
so if I lower my slope notice I'm
flattening out the line that's a slope
of 0 let's go has to be even more
negative than that let's see maybe even
more negative than that right has to
look like a line that goes BAM just down
like that even more that looks close let
me get my y-intercept down to see if I
can get closer to that my y-intercept it
still seems like my slope is a little
bit too high that looks better so let me
get my y-intercept down even further
it's now intersecting way here off the
screen you can't even see that and I
just realize it says copyright 2008 Khan
Academy it's now 2009 it's almost near
the end of 2009 I need to change that
you'll just write 2010 there okay so
y-intercept even more so I'll lower the
y-intercept but our slope is still not
strong enough and the y-intercepts
actually off the chart it's intersecting
it minus 18 that's our current
y-intercept but the slope of -5 is still
not enough so let me lower the slope so
if I lower the slope let's see if I
lower the y-intercept a little bit more
is that getting me there you go it got
me to those points so the equation of
the line that passes through both of
those things is minus 6x minus 22 let's
do another one so once again it's resets
it so I just say the equation 1x plus 1
but it gives me these two new points
that I have to make it go through and
once again this is going to be a
negative slope right because for every X
that I move forward positive my Y is
actually going down so I'm going to have
a negative slope here so let me lower
the slope a little bit let me lower the
slope it's actually doing fractions so
this thing jumps around a little bit I
should probably change that a little bit
that looks about right so let me shift
the graph down a little bit by lowering
its y-intercept by lowering its
y-intercept can I hit those two points
there you go this is the equation of
that line that goes to the points -5 1
and the point 9 minus 9 you have a slope
of minus 5/7 for every seven you go to
the right you go down five right if you
go one two three four five six seven
you're going to go down one two three
four five and that we definitely feel
that on that line and then the
y-intercept is minus 18
over seven which is a little over two
it's about a little over its what a
little over two and a half and we see
right there that the y-intercept is a
little over two and a half and that's
the equation for our line let's do
another one this is a fun module because
there's no wrong answers you can just
keep messing with it until you
eventually get that line to go through
both of those points but the idea is
really to give you that intuition that
the slope is just what the inclination
of the line is and then the y-intercept
is where how far up and down it gets
shifted so this is going to be a
positive slope but not as high as one it
looks like for every let's see one two
three four five six seven eight nine ten
eleven twelve for every 12 we go to the
right we're going to go one two three up
so our slope is going to be three over
twelve which is also one over four we
can just look at that visually let's
lower our slope that's three four it's
not low enough one half not low enough
one fourth which I just figured out it
is that looks right and then we have to
lower the y-intercept the Y and we're
shifting it down and there we go so this
the equation of this line it's slope is
one fourth is one for it so the equation
of line is one fourth X plus one fourth
so hopefully that for those of you
trying to do this module that one
explains how to do it and for those of
you who don't even know what this module
is it hopefully gives you a little
intuition about what the slope and the
y-intercept do to an actual line